all right crystal your first Bravo con
yes how are you feeling it's it's also
like your first like back in the real
world with all the fans
I don't know if this is real world I
mean this is like outer body world but
it's a lot of fun we are in the midst of
this reunion part one was tough on you
it was like the crystal show why can't
you guys allow us to be okay I think
it's great that you're okay but I spent
three episodes watching wondering what
this dark comment was make this a
learning experience The Learning
Experience seems to be don't accuse
someone of saying something specifically
very dark on time because exactly it
seems like these women just do not
understand the words that come out of
your mouth is there anything you want to
clear up maybe they should go to college
and then they'll learn the words I use
I just realized there's
can't
um yeah that's all maybe college or
maybe a dictionary yeah I feel like
we've talked about the dictionary for
two years now so it's time that they get
some yeah actually I think it's I'm just
gonna invest
and just buy them all dictionaries and
maybe it'll help it's not anthropology I
didn't give you an apology for the word
sorry that you're upset that is not an
apology Look up the word it is an abuse
of privacy in the part two teas we got
it looks like it gets heated again for
you and Kyle where do you two stand
after reunion did you leave in a good
place well she left in a dip she had
other stuff going on I left in a great
place so uh but yeah I mean I haven't
seen her since but we've shared niceties
on social so you know you'll see her a
lot this weekend yeah your pal Kathy
Hilton is also here who I think pulled
out maybe an MVP title at a reunion
right excuse me with what she delivers
what did we get do we get answers to
what happened in Aspen from her yeah I
think she clarifies her side of the
story uh again I as a millennial I like
to be open to everyone's side of the
story but she gets to express hers and
she came on strong and that's Kathy
where do you think the group stands they
believe Kathy do they believe Rina the
truth is somewhere in between the truth
is always somewhere in between feel like
that in most cases and I think that
every
every it's it's in between just depends
on what part of scale you're on that's
all how do you feel about written as
performance at the reunion she said put
me on and it's kind of intense and all
the sneak peeks look I think Brynn is an
actor so sometimes it gets a little bit
like elevated but as you said it's the
performance I don't know but I I've
gotten to spend time with Rena off
camera and so I think you know there's
this energy when you walk into reunion I
don't have it but I can feel the girls
are ready to go who've been on for a
long time and I think that's really
weird yeah you were ready to twerk it
and get your lower region Sage I think
I'm the only one that went out to dinner
after I met like a bunch of friends and
I think everyone the rest went home
crying and mad
foreign